[Music]
[Music]
all right people we're back if Laci
green wasn't enough for you well we've
got more we are once again live on the
YouTube and on Facebook and joining me
now with only a half-hour break I am the
hardest-working man not in show biz
joining me today is a mathematician an
economist the managing director of teal
Capital and now a man that I call my
friend and confidant eric weinstein
welcome back great to be back everybody
reporting
hooray how you doing Riley I'm doing
pretty well how about you I am good I'm
glad you're here on a day that I'm doing
two live streams and and a show later
this afternoon
that's not live because I feel like this
is a perfect metaphor for life right now
there's just so much going on and I mean
so fast happening so fast the world's
that we exist in the political world the
economic world the philosophic world all
of these things feel like they're upside
down you know we're having Tripoli with
Lacey and Chris Raygun ten minutes ago
now we're sitting here doing this like
just worlds are colliding so much is
happening at once yeah and you know I
come back to my earlier point it does
feel in many ways that you found the
Nexus where all these things have to
meet and so I think it's been extremely
interesting watching this develop I mean
the your progression has happened on
online and I think that there's probably
in my opinion no place I'd rather come
to try to sort this out and I keep
asking people where do we reboot from
what is our last safe restore point from
which we can get into safe mode and you
know one of the reasons I'm so excited
to be here is that I think you're doing
the best job of anybody on that well I
appreciate that I think as a math guy
and a physics guy you're describing me
as a black hole is that not what you're
saying that I exist and I'm sucking all
of these things into me and what comes
out on the other side we do not know
well that you so there might be a bit of
a wormhole where things wind up on Joe
Rogan or or Tucker Carlson
or Sam Harris but I do think that one of
the great things is the ability to you
know to do what you do is you get out of
the way and you let people either
explain themselves hang themselves it's
up to them so that's what's so
terrifying about being you're on a live
stream yes well I'm gonna be letting you
hang yourself okay Wow okay so first
what I want to talk about so there's a
ton that we're gonna talk about and and
not only what I think is great about
this is that we've become very good
friends and but even beyond that you're
one of the people that when I know
something is up I had an issue earlier
in the week related to some professional
stuff I knew I can get you on the phone
and that you you know you can get advice
from anybody but there's only so many
people in life that you go oh their
advice is the advice I'm supposed to
listen to and you've become one of those
panels for me and so now let's get into
some stuff that was see what I did there
was I paid you a compliment so that now
I can give you the rope to hang I really
appreciate the false sense that was
impressive okay I want to put your
brother first because your brother is
Brett Weinstein from Evergreen State
College was a former guest of the Reuben
report and apparently vile hateful
racist everyone knows the story already
so we don't have to reclaim the story or
even retell the story but I want to know
from you watching your brother right go
through this incident for those that you
want to give a 1-minute recap for those
that may not know sure just a 1-minute
recap more or less the world found my
brother in his sleepy hideaway in
Olympia Washington where he has been
taking this very unconventional college
called the Evergreen State College and
he effectively hacked it and turned it
into something it was never before which
is a tiny little Harvard of the
Northwest where he pretends in some
sense that his undergraduates or
graduate students he gets them right
into the heart of evolutionary theory
and he is a guy if you know him who is
just so profoundly and deeply that
compassionate ethical and thoughtful
that when his campus decided to explore
sending a message that white faculty
staff
and students who wish to show solidarity
with students of color most particularly
black students that they were invited to
leave campus for a day he objected and
the real problem with this story is that
his letter of objection of protests that
followed where he was protesting against
segregation and strangely the black
students and students of color were
protesting for segregation so it's a bit
of a mind flip
yeah but the big problem is I don't
think anybody's actually gotten to the
heart of this story which is something
far more disturbing than is what's
usually covered and that is that there
is one place that is left in which open
racism can be practiced institutionally
in the US and that's through this
diversity equity movement in which it
appears to be you can be openly anti
white openly anti straight openly anti
male and that this is considered
progressive and of course this extends
to being anti West you're allowed to be
openly anti-jewish anti-israel not from
the perspective of is there nothing to
criticize right but just getting to
levels which you have a cult effectively
that has redefined words like racism or
sexism
so that particular groups can never be
sexist or racist and other groups can
never be anything but yeah and I like
that you mentioned words there because
one of the things that I think you're
you're really good at because you
operate I think in two levels you
operated a very sort of high
mathematical physical physics level and
then you operate in a level where you're
trying to communicate some of those
ideas through words often through
Twitter and in a more simple way for
regular people such as myself to
understand and you've come up with some
great phrases that we're gonna knock out
I used one of your phrases the think
juez ition when you were the first
person that mentioned it to me and I
thought this is a I like this word it
captures
something going for it but before we get
to that so just on your brother real
quick right forgetting the story of your
mother just to stand with your brother
going through something right hearing
that your brother who you know is not
racist or has fought racism right in his
life knowing him from birth what what
was I like to stand with him in the in
the midst of this haywire storm was
terrible for him in many ways was great
for me because you find out you know
okay so suddenly your brother's most
famous races it's a particular day in
American history and you're trying to
think like okay I understand I'm
supposed to recoil and horror and you
know a friend of ours the Nassim Taleb
has this wonderful word anti fragile and
the anti fragile thing to do is to say
no you're not gonna scare me off why
don't you just assume that I'm every
name that you want to call me you want
to call me xenophobe do you want to call
me sexist racist do you want to call me
a bigot a pig etc so why don't you to
empty your arsenal and then we can have
a conversation because those words are
just intended to scare everyone off the
thing about Brett I mean it's really
painful to have to you spar with a guy
your entire life they have to say really
nice but it's true right I mean first of
all the guy's got a ton of integrity
he's been he sacrificed his own career
in his own trajectory to stand up for
people less powerful and less fortunate
this guy walks the walk he talks to talk
they couldn't have picked a worse target
he's absolutely the nightmare that they
didn't understand they didn't know that
he'd left college to stand up for black
women who were being exploited and
because he has no fear or concern that
he's a racist these words don't really
mean the same thing it's not like he's
thinking well I did have those three bad
thoughts you know over the last five
years he's just never had them and you
know his evolutionary theory informs his
worldview and one of the things people
haven't found out about him and I hope
he's not watching this but he's pretty
much a straight-up genius of
evolutionary theory he's not just some
random guy who got picketed
and I don't know whether that story is
gonna come out he was the leading
student of a guy named dick Alexander
who was one of the absolute top four or
five evolutionary theorists in the world
and because that field came under such
pressure in the 70s when people didn't
want to apply the insights that come
from evolutionary theory to humans the
field has been in terrible state and
that was in part why you find him at
this crazy place but this is the top
student of one of the or at least two of
the top living evolutionary theorists so
he's going he's going to blow the world
away on several topics that have nothing
to do with protests or or politics or
anything like this we just haven't
gotten to his science yet does that in a
weird way show you the danger of what's
happening on college campuses that if a
guy who has a human is as decent as you
say and I spent I've only spent about
three hours with him total - or on
camera but strikes me as a very decent
honest you know humble human being but
who also is doing the academic work
leader Toria that that really shows that
what's happening on the college the
danger of it because it's a warning shot
to everybody else coming after our best
people yeah they are coming after the
people who are the least racist the most
forward-thinking the most thoughtful the
most nuanced this is no coincidence the
idea is you can cow mows people with
this stuff but when a guy has literally
given up an Ivy League education under
death threats to stand up for those less
fortunate he's probably not losing a lot
of sleep over his own racism and you
know you can say what everybody's
racially you know racist yeah
everybody's racially aware we can show
the the neuroscience studies that show
that people identify even if you put a
bracelet around a hand to show that
somebody is in your affinity group not
in your affinity group even if it's a
rubberized hand you stick a fork in it
and suddenly if you're an atheist and
the bracelet says atheist the you know
the reaction will spike through the roof
so we know that there's affinity we know
that there's you know some sort of
latent kind of racism and everyone
including blacks not
not limited just to whites and this is
the guy who's the most aware he can give
you the science he can give the even the
introspection and that's why this was
like also sort of hysterically funny
when the dust settles and everybody's
out of harm's way we're gonna look back
at this and say wow they picked on Brett
Weinstein that's how crazy this got so
not only did they pick on the wrong guy
but it exposed not only what was
happening at Evergreen in terms of the
administration but in terms of
everything the stuff that I really care
about beyond the college stuff is the
media stuff and I think it exposed
something else related to the media it
got virtually no coverage for the first
couple weeks then it got a little bit of
something but really he did Tucker was
the first big piece he did the Tucker
Carlson on Fox News that which was the
only offer he got of the big three cable
news things as far as I know then he did
my show and a couple laters he did Rogan
that kind of put his piece on the map
and then slowly there were some stories
but they were all written by
conservative sites there was virtually
nothing I can't swear that there was
nothing I think eventually off PO did
touch it and maybe a couple others but
it was all all the defense of this man
was coming from the things that are
thought of as right or far-right or alt
right like that scary Joe Rogan I mean
that's how stupid thing is so what does
that say about the state of the media
well that's what that was my original
point which is we just saw the best
demonstration we're ever going likely to
get that the New York Times will not
cover a story like this in real time if
it is exactly counter-narrative mm-hmm
and the problem with this it's a little
bit like sailing where you're trying to
go backwards you know relative to the
way the wind is blowing you haven't
figured out tacking yet you know so this
narrative is exactly counter to the
mainstream narrative this is terrible
racism on campus and it's black racism
against White's so right the mind
immediately explodes because for example
people are experimenting inside of this
cult with the idea that racism is no
longer have the law defines it or how
your dictionary defines it
no it's PowerPlus privilege and since
the underprivileged have no power they
can't be racist
QED one side is always good the other
side is always bad this kind of
intellectual sleight of hand is in
danger of being exposed and so what I
think was happening is that they were
waiting for him to foot fault mm-hmm you
know just waiting for a moment where
he'd be on one of these shows live and
accidentally effect yeah and by the way
you know we can say this is the only
offer he got but I'm tired of that right
Tucker Carlson came through yeah
and you know I've objected to plenty of
things Tucker Carlson has done but I'm
not going to apologize for where we show
up I will go to any program I like I
will affiliate and talk to people who I
like who I don't like who I may think
are abhorrent but are personally rather
engaging I mean this idea that one set
of people controls how another set of
people can affiliate and associate what
program can you be on like the funniest
story and this is really just crazy yeah
is Brett Weinstein endangered Evergreen
State College by going on Tucker Carlson
oh I saw this thing written in just in
the last couple days about this yeah but
on the bald right worker calls and
nobody calls Tucker Carlson all right
nobody knows are these people on like
fundamentally you're so sheltered in
your bubble that look Fox News that's a
lot of propaganda it does a lot of hit
pieces it does lots of things they don't
like as the New York Times but the idea
that we're going to say that Tucker
Carlson is beyond the pale and the New
York Times which won't even report the
story after I think they did three op
eds before they actually sent a reporter
to to write about which is actually kind
of crazy I mean that's really a crazy
way for them to be exposing so to speak
a story what's traditionally write the
op-ed has been almost completely
divorced from the paper by a Chinese
wall and so it reflects the fact that it
is the narrative driven news department
that is the problem mm-hmm because it is
that the cryptic op-ed right that's what
the front page is it's the cryptic op-ed
because it's telling you a narrative
please feel this way you are Ingrid you
were the wise you were the clever these
people are the bad they are backwards
they're problematic they're troubled and
so this kind of aid that nobody wants
which is how should I feel today
indicates that this was a non-story it's
not worthy of your attention so you see
a story that is not showing up it's the
dog that doesn't bark that is much more
important so yeah he absolutely proved
out this theory which is that's not a
newspaper a newspaper would have covered
what the op-eds spent three op-eds doing
yeah and it's so interesting because I
know I can feel it as you're saying it I
know that a certain amount of people who
like you who like me are gonna hear what
you just said maybe understand that at
an intellectual level but then go whoa
whoa whoa he's comparing the New York
Times to Fox News and that's so counter
to the way we're supposed to think about
these it's not just them it's me i sat
down at my mother's dining table this
morning and I looked at the font and
that font has this mystical hold the New
York Times and all the news that's fit
to print and somehow right you think
they could have got one story about
right in there all the news is kind of
not fit yeah I don't know not fit right
if you run it backwards but I can't
shake the idea that the New York Times
because it is so close to being a
newspaper right it is a hair's breadth
away and that's this is what I call the
uncanny valley of journalism where if
you remember Polar Express it was too
realistic without being realistic and so
because it was hyper real you're right
yeah and so that's why the New York
Times is the top of my problem list it's
because it's so close to being a
newspaper in fact checks it's
beautifully written it does do a good
job of developing a story but I don't
want my story to be real time historical
fiction I don't want at the end known by
the writer before they even start
writing because the news is coming in
it's a it's a data stream yeah and this
is where we should quickly throw in a
phrase that you've given me which I
which I
love that you mentioned last time the
Russell conjugation basically that you
can almost figure out what the story is
just from the headline and then often
what's in the body of it doesn't quite
line up yeah we see this all the time
I mean is he embattled professor Brett
wise is a controversial professor bright
where I said is he heroic professor
Brett Weinstein is he mild-mannered is
he progressive is he a racist you're
constantly giving me all of these cues
and if I just turned off your audio if I
if I screen out the emotional
instructions here's a guy who did
absolutely nothing wrong in fact he did
the right thing he stood up he did
everything we wanted a professor yeah
and the fact is that this is terrifying
to the administrators because what
happened was there's a trend there is a
cult and there is a movement the trend
is for administrators to displace
faculty in terms of their autonomy this
is why the administration's are all
exploding and the costs are going up
there is a cult which is this postmodern
cult that's coming out of the humanities
where the relativism becomes some kind
of Marxism and suddenly the only thing
we know is that everything is oppression
and then you have a movement which is
you've got a bunch of kids who feel that
they should be active they shouldn't be
complacent they want to see a better
world they do detect structural
inequities and they want to get active
and do something just to be applauded
the big problem isn't the movement it
was the trend figuring that it could
count on the cult to achieve an end and
the end was to attenuate the power of
the faculty and so if the president
could simply push through this equity
proposal and that would eliminate some
freedom in hiring and force diversity
targets in terms of how many people of
color how many people the right gender
how many homosexuals etc etc which is in
general not something that is thought to
be very good to do on the outcome and
you might want to drive equality of
opportunity but the last thing you want
to do when you're trying to find the
best mathematician the best physicist
the best biologist is to consider any of
that
and and even the way you know it's funny
the way you said homosexual instead of
gay there I think is the kind of entry
like it sounds a little Nazi like then
you know do you mean like I know that
wasn't your intention like but make it
sound naughty like but when you say it
that way like we should have a certain
amount of women then and a certain
amount of homosexuals there's like a
Nazi connotation - well I just find that
the part of it that's so offensive is
that this this will happen naturally if
we fundamentally are just more decent we
take we take the time that we that we
need I mean we didn't know how many
let's say gays we had in mathematics
when I was in math departments very
often I would think the apart entire
department was straight and I only found
out later no no no gays represented for
some time you can do math you absolutely
you know I mean there's even this
question of course about a couple of
extra IQ point advantage that has come
up but I think that what they were
trying to do is is that this president
wanted to change the nature of the
college and he couldn't have done that
but the Faculty's help I mean it started
with the Faculty's resistance and so
Brett was the only guy who said it I'm
standing up why aren't there more
Braille one sighs why aren't there more
Jordan Pederson why can I count the
number of these people on one hand doing
three hands because I think they've been
cowed into silence I think well this is
the modern University
if tenure is supposed to guarantee
freedom of thought right academic
freedom and I can't hear much of
anything what does that tell us right so
in a weird way acted by giving
professors tenure ship you've put now
this undue pressure on the
administration to bend when they
shouldn't because the professor's aren't
going anywhere they're still protecting
their own butts in many cases you can
fire professors yeah well don't
understand this what you do is you you
up there teaching loads you put them in
crappy offices you make them hate their
jobs and then they'll remove themselves
right and so the big problem is the
administration finding the cult and that
when the trend tried to use the cult to
displace the faculty in its autonomy and
go after the sciences
you know we have on video the president
of the university talking to the people
leading the protest that a short time
before that everything all hell breaks
lives and they're talking about what
Brett used the word genetics he used the
word phenotype what does that tell you
it tells you he's a biologist you [ __ ]
tells you he's thinking about race at a
very deep level he's he's thinking about
socially and he's thinking about it
biologically but the idea is that
somehow vaguely that sounds like I don't
know some kind of weird eugenics thing
to you right and then what they start
talking about is we're going to use
diversity training as a weapon we're
gonna bring them in we're gonna train
them and if that doesn't take then we
sanction that yeah okay we have that on
tape and then the president right says
there are going to be people who are
gonna just tell us all to [ __ ] off
that's what he says in those words and
then he turns right to somebody
recording this he says don't put that in
the video he throws up his hands because
the kids laugh like a horse right this
is this is a different generation yeah I
got every that in the video and so what
is it he's owned this is compromised
they've been videoing him and people
can't figure out well why does he allow
them to tell him when he can go to the
bathroom whether he needs an escort
literally you're not making that up this
president is still in office what does
that tell you something is wrong
above president the president it's wrong
at the level of the trustees we don't
know what this is but one can infer this
guy created a public hazard by telling
the police to stand down he's now
claiming that the police don't have
enough guns irony none at all
irony lying yeah right he created this
situation and somebody's leaving him in
place this is the first failed college
or university that we've ever had to the
best of my knowledge in that it was a
real place but the failure went above
the president the failure is now at the
level of the trustees mm-hmm like a
failed state yeah all right well I know
we could we could just keep going with
that because it's so relative and and
relatable to everything else we're going
to talk about
but the media component of that I think
is where I've spent most of my time I
talk obviously a lot about the kalos
stuff in the free speech but the media
component I see is directly related to
so much of the Trump stuff right now oh
boy so so let's go into that Trump stuff
because to me I had Andrew Klavan on
last week he described Trump as
basically just running a truck through
mainstream media and just blowing the
whole thing up
I've used the analogy that it's like
Trump has just thrown the chess board up
we can figure out a zillion I use
wrecking ball wrecking ball right so I
was gonna say I know you've got a good
analogy for this that part has been the
part that I have focused on that I think
is good it's immeasurably good this
corruption that you're talking about
this endless sucking up to power the way
they use words the way they trick us to
think all of these things I see as a net
good of the Trump thing none of that has
anything to do with do I wish we had a
president that I trusted more or that I
felt had a moral Center that I
understood or didn't tweet as much or
was elevating dialogue or all of those
things and again I didn't even vote for
the guy but that thing I think is really
damn good about him so first off do you
do you agree with that premise in the
first place I don't think so and I'm not
even positive that you do so let me let
me advance an argument bring it as we as
if we were talking on the phone as we do
that's why I have you here okay I think
that the problem is is that he's not a
clean enough wrecking ball and that this
is backfiring all right so the idea is
that I view the Democratic Party and the
associated media whether it's CNN NPR
New York Times as electing Donald Trump
more or less it would be impossible to
produce him without this kind of
institutionalized corruption whether or
not the corruption is legal or illegal
doesn't matter to me it subverts the
intent of the process okay so if I don't
like it okay now the problem is is that
they are going to protect us from all of
the excesses of Donald Trump and there
are many expenses of Donald row there's
no shortage Yeah right and so the
problem is is that they've both
lit the house on fire and offered their
services as firemen to put out the fire
that they start so the problem that I'm
having is I want Trump to be cleaner so
that the message has actually received
we have two new problems we have a host
of what can it best be called
non-standard presidential behavior
mm-hmm and right yeah and at worst we
have a group of people who had no plan
for governance because the only plan
that I mean you know this is something I
got it wrong I definitely thought anyone
smart enough to win the White House
using this crazy strategy which I felt I
understood some would have some plan for
governance and then it had it had to
have a certain component which is they
were going to fill up government with
the loyalists first they were going to
give less important positions to the
less competent loyalists and then they
were gonna have to broaden their circle
and go to non-hostile left-leaning
competence because there just wasn't
enough pro Trump stuff you need bodies
at the end of the day if you're gonna do
sign anything scientifically based
science is gonna lean heavily Democratic
so let's just take that as an example so
I always knew that you were gonna run
through the number of Republican or
Trump supporting and physicists
biologists mathematicians very quickly
all right was there ever a plan to
actually staff this government
apparently not so what does that tell
you on on the loyalist front because I
think that's an interesting spot so when
you look at guys that were thought of as
the the loyal attack dogs chris Christie
didn't get a job in the administration
Rudy Giuliani didn't get a job in the
administration Mike Huckabee didn't get
you know all these old-school
politicians but who were very effective
for him do you think that that was part
of the plan in a way you know you mean
like you use them as long as you need
them and then you toss them out or do
they provide some other cover by not
being part of the government it would
appear that there was no plan so you
think that's really the the broader
piece here I I worried that I had a
better handle on Trump's odds than Trump
had on
I'm solids because I don't think that
this I don't think any of this was not
foreseeable I mean I always thought it
was gonna be a close election and if
they were going to govern this had this
shift it had you know you have to spend
your chrysalis because a campaign is not
an administration and that message has
not happened so you know the question
about where I am with Trump and I
brought this up to you the other night
why why don't you and I criticize Trump
more in the public sphere I thought was
a good question for us because I noticed
that I'm not doing it very much yeah but
I also noticed that I've been absolutely
unambiguous in my old tweeting saying
you know I view this as an existential
risk and you know so to answer it for me
one I'm very troubled that the one guy
who snuck through is so complicated and
noisy then unclean in terms of like you
know nor signal-to-noise ratio that
we're not getting the message that
people voted against something and they
they didn't have a none of the above
category like none of the above would
have wouldn't want a no answer right
just like which part of we don't want
Donna Brazile coming back we do not want
debbie Wasserman Schultz please do not
give us yeah Rubio or Cruz or any of
these people like the whole slate not
not workable but so then isn't that so
wait so first I'm still not sure which
is the part of what I said that you
think I don't really believe well I'm
concerned that we're not actually
getting a great effect of having Trump
do the wrecking ball thing so that I
agree with the whole thing is a freaking
mess right but but I also think you know
I've had a few people say this to me
privately lately that they which is sort
of what you just said that I I don't
mind the wrecking ball I saw this
horrible stuff but I wanted it to be a
little softer you know I wish instead of
having the bull charged through the
china shop couldn't have been you know
like you know like a panther that would
have smashed a couple things but been
slicked around other things and whatever
and to me it's like that just that's a
nice idea but it could have never broke
rooo this is something that I've been
admonished by many people that you know
which part of bull in a china shop
you're really thinking about some
surgical right so to your point maybe it
wasn't possible but I can't believe that
we're gonna lose this much
infrastructure mm-hmm and we're gonna
double down just to get rid of this
administration that's the plan like more
identity politics more laughing about
economic nationalism mm-hmm as if
economic nationalism isn't the reason
for the Democratic Party in large
measure mm-hmm like they abandoned it
and you know Steve Bannon picked it up
and we're not going to get the pendulum
swinging through a central point it's
just the pendulum is going crazy and
chaotic because nobody can interpret
what just happens so is that what
happens after this no matter what oh is
that almost preordained at this point
that the sides have now gone so bananas
that whether they impeach him or
something with Russia or they just
relentlessly you know destroy him for
four years or he does something great
and then that makes them go even more
crazy that the pendulum I like that it's
supposed to go like this and instead
it's gonna just like we've almost
entered this new phase now where it's
just gonna go in directions that it
shouldn't don't like we you left the
little balloon go full of gas and it
just goes around the room and it's on
Brownian motion pattern and I believe
there is one over overarching crisis
mm-hmm and I call it the crisis in semi
reliable communal sense making and it's
effectively that there's no place to go
to sort out what happened I know if I
want to hear that things are as bad as
can be with Trump and treason
I know exactly which outlets yeah if I
want to hear that everything is
absolutely fine it's a witch-hunt
there's never anything there I know
which outlets what I'm looking for is
for some group of people to look at this
independently and come up with a relic
civilly narrow cluster of you know this
part is really bad this part is a little
bit bad but it's more or less a foot
fault
this got blown out of proportion
somebody help me understand you know you
have experts who understand the rules of
parliamentary procedure so help me
understand the laws you have somebody
who has an idea of history help me with
the history nobody is doing that without
using the opportunity to push an agenda
you know it's so interesting here
because just even in the last couple of
days when this Trump jr. thing has
happened with the email you know a month
ago everybody was saying it was Comey
these are all the gotcha moments we've
got him this time we've got it this time
and Twitter blows up and everyone says
this is it this is it is it then
basically nothing happened nothing came
of it there was no investigation nothing
came all that then the Trump doing your
hat thing happens the same people who
were saying this is it this is it this
is it a month ago we're saying this is
it a month ago now we'll see maybe this
thing is different we shall see you know
what I mean but that's sort of like
we're just waiting for the answer we
want we're waiting for the answer we
want we're always gonna bend things to
the answer we want is a problem and
again I say this as someone that did not
even vote for the guy right I don't see
a way out and I here are my best hopes
and none of them are great one of them
is that we actually pushed the Potemkin
village into this concept which I called
D Potemkin ization where you you realize
that you're living on the Truman Show
and you decide you're actually going to
build out the world that it's is
suggested by the set fronts like so we
finally we take the New York Times it's
not a newspaper we turn it into a
newspaper it's got most of the equipment
there's no reason it can't be repurposed
yeah how we're gonna do that I don't
know but we have we'd have to put
pressure on it so the big problem here
is who would put that pressure to turn
something that is a functioning very
effectively as a pseudo newspaper that
advances a narrative into a newspaper
like that's very hard to see how do you
get the democratic party donor class to
effectively go against their own
interests because their only interest in
that party for example may be protecting
their particular you know exemption that
allows them to profit
and so it's very hard so now you mean in
this case you mean having the donor
class go against the identity politics
stuff and go against all that stuff that
you see is so destructive well they'd
have to just say and we can't fund this
anymore
and we don't know what it's gonna work
what would the French aristocracy have
done if it wanted to stave off the
French Revolution it would probably have
thought maybe we're gagging people a bit
much right right yeah yeah they're all
out on the streets looking for bread
right so I'm very I'm very concerned
that we not lose compassion for people
who are hurting and expressing
themselves terribly you know they may
not be expressing themselves well
through identity politics but people are
hurting and they're afraid and growth is
lousy and people don't have confidence
that everything's going to be okay and I
think they have reason to worry so we
have to get into touch with it and I
think that we also have to you know to
try to be just tasteful and moderate
like look we're not getting rid of
wealth some people are more successful
than others some people work harder some
people manage risk better on the other
hand we can't just claim that every
fortune that makes no sense
that came about because those people
contributed more to the economy clearly
there's a ton of rent-seeking so if we
don't understand the decency is a little
bit like a fire extinguisher you know in
a case of emergency use decency like we
caught it with the house is gonna yeah
it's gonna blow right now you're
speaking my language well and and then
then we have this other hope so one hope
is that the institutions that are
largely internally different than their
exterior would suggest that you hope
that CNN Harvard Brookings etc all the
things I usually pick on become deep
Temkin eyes the other thing is is that
you look at non-standard places like the
Reuben report like the waking up podcast
like sargon of a cat all these crazy
lunatics who you're assembling in some
sense yeah and that becomes something
truly new because this is the only place
that I can come to think and to your
point when I feel like I'm not
understanding what's going on I can't
plug in with a relative who's still in
the old world
and so we're dependent upon each other
in our back channels like hey something
really weird happened on Twitter seven
people started with the exact same point
I'm I'm thinking that that's not real
those are sock puppets
if somebody's never heard of
astroturfing they have no idea what
you're talking about then you sound like
a conspiracy theorist whereas somebody
else will say yeah I've got seven sock
pocket puppets in them I'm trolling you
funny huh I don't know how many times
I've called you just in the last three
months and but and started the
conversation with Eric I don't want to
go too far down the rabbit hole Eric I
don't want to be too conspiratorial here
but I find that that talking with
someone about some of the crazy earth
you know we're all having thoughts all
day long especially in especially in an
upside down time we're all having all
sorts of crazy thoughts and I think
having that that core group of whoever
it is for anyone watching this but
having a group that will allow you to
express your thoughts without jumping
down your throat or allow you to you
know mention something that sounds a
little weird it's so important right now
it's probably this is as important as it
could possibly be right now but that I
mean I feel like we are a community and
you know one of the funny things about
being recognized like here we are in a
totally fake TV show what right it's
well I just for the record this is
extremely professional around here I
mean it is professional but the point is
it didn't say what is this NBC yeah yeah
no it's like something you dreamed up
right now that thing that you dreamed up
I can tell you how important it is
because I get recognized in Trader Joe's
people are Eric Weinstein I'm thinking
did I go to high school with you know
you know this thing is being watched by
millions of people and and it's not just
you so the I think that the you know
five to twenty five channels that are
exploring these topics are it's
neck-and-neck
either the mainstream institutions
reboot because they can't take the pain
anymore which I don't think is happening
because they're getting a lot of
reinforcement now Trump Trump is so
crazy thank God we're here to save you
all you know yeah so in a weird way he's
getting he's given them their biggest
foil and he's also given their
Redemption and sometimes I do think that
that like you guys are all in it on it
together like Trump is sort of in on it
with CNN I'm gonna keep saying crazy
[ __ ] and you're gonna keep getting
clicks cuz well that that is certainly
happening yeah I don't think that but
they must love this they must love this
feeling of we finally once again are
your scene well they're certainly
they're pinning themselves as I don't
think most people believe it but they
have to love that self-importance right
I think that they do and I think that
you know democracy dies in darkness you
know I hope somebody got a chuckle when
they were when they were thinking about
whether to bring that back right you
know they see themselves in this
incredibly sanctimonious heroic capacity
and quite frankly they're not taking you
know you and I are taking real risk
doing this stuff and I don't think
they're taking real risk I don't think
that they're breaking a sweat they're
phoning it and they're doing what
they've always done but now there's a
slight uptick in the demand where is the
resistance we will rid ourselves of this
terrible well whatever you think about
him you obviously were willing to dance
with the devil during the campaign to
bring this in yeah nobody told you you
had to put illegal aliens you know
onstage at the DNC even if you think
that there should be an amnesty program
you're just specifically sticking your
finger people lies yeah what do you
think about the concept that we all sort
of conjured this up I know I mean that
in the sorta yeah but I mean it in sort
of like the matrix kind of way and a
little bit of Harry Potter and I look
like that was all in a weird way we
almost wanted this this insanity right
now you know like we we were all so
obsessed with the election and all the
stuff and we got this thing but here it
is we got it a day I'm so nervous that
we've broken something really deep that
this is not but I think maybe
subconsciously we all intended well I
wanted to get off I wanted to get I
wanted to get out of that rut and I
believe that between the end of the
Carter Administration and 2008 you know
I call it the extended Reagan
administration it was pretty bad it was
pretty consistent the major players have
been playing these games for long before
the internet allowed us to catch them at
it and to say hey did you see that weird
thing that they did which is you know a
lot of what gives us strength but you
know I think if you look at the
desperation to exit that structure I
don't think many of us would put at risk
what we just put at risk because I the
institution's aren't safe and the big
difference between Trump in my opinion
and the institution's is that Trump is
representing a very bizarre presentation
of the individual this guy is a
contrarian he doesn't listen to other
people he goes his own way all these
Maverick sensibilities but there's only
one Trump it's not like there's you know
a hundred Trump's ready to take over
from him you can't even pawn things off
to Jared or Steve Bannon or Steven
Miller yeah so the bigot the bigger
issue is is is Trump really the
existential risk because we're gonna get
into something with North Korea that we
should be avoiding because he doesn't
know how to do this or is the
existential risk that we are sitting
here waiting for our institutions to rot
from the inside as we never tire of
putting failed baby boomer ideology in
their service i fee I think I probably
fear that more in the long term I think
I probably fear that these things were
crumbling or not only crumbling the way
I've described it is that to me a vote
for Hillary and again I voted for Gary
Johnson but a vote really would have
just tightened the screws against all of
us all of us that were seeing the things
that you're talking about it would have
been a tightening of that against us a
choking a taking the air out of the room
for us now we've got something that may
end up destroying all of the
institutions but yeah I think we've done
is we've unleashed a multipolar world
where the u.s. is not capable of giving
strong guidance so what we're doing is
we are now squandering what we built for
decades in the post-world War two
rearrangement and we're gonna be left
probably with a multipolar world which
game theoretically is gonna be almost
impossible to control I mean the Cold
War was weirdly stable because it was
two-player mm-hmm yeah and now there's a
lot more players all right here's what
we're gonna do because I really want to
get to this what we have sitting on the
desk in front of us but you have come up
with you know my policy is I like to not
look at my notes when a caucus is
selling here we you failed me miserably
but you've come up as I mentioned before
you kind of play in two worlds you play
in the in the sort of mathematics
physics economics world and then you
play in the Twitter world too and you
try to get some of those ideas out there
to be understood in in a more palatable
way I think for sort of regulars people
so to speak so I just want to go up with
a couple things that I've seen you tweet
out lately and we'll just spend a couple
minutes on terrific so as I said you
were the one that originally said the
phrase Inquisition to me I think I laid
it out pretty decently in that correct
message but this idea of the the attack
the idea of the attack on ideas right is
the new Inquisition that we have going
on right now and it also fits
beautifully with this very strange
phenomena that a lot of people who have
always identified left or progressive or
with the Democratic Party are finding
themselves
weirdly hanging out with people on the
right and I think why is this and so I
thought about this situation like during
the Inquisition in Spain where you know
Turkey said you know Spain's problem
with with the Jews is Turkey's advantage
welcome and so in large measure a lot of
us have been treated much better on the
right and I believe that the right is
actually softening and changing as a
result of them taking in this influx of
people who you know I've never voted
Republican yet I'm not I don't even
think I'm on the fence necessarily but I
do know that I am treated respectfully
thoughtfully people say well I'll
disagree with you Eric on that and then
we find out that maybe we're not in so
much disagreement so the quality of the
conversations on the right has become
weirdly better
than what I used to you know I often
refer to as the thinking left and it's
it's watching the expulsion of one group
and into territory traditionally held by
another and I do think we have to be
really appreciative to our friends on
the right for their decency and at some
point when the right you know starts
checking out people who dare to think
for themselves I hope to offer them a
home when we've regained our own
territory yeah and I love that because
it does show the fluidity of all of this
and the rhythm of all of this and the
things that it were right become left
and the balance and all that but I think
you hit something really interesting
there which is that I think you said
they've been softening and I've
consistently seen that so when I've sat
across in this very room from people on
the right you know the scary right so
Prager and Shapiro and Glenn Beck and
all these other people well they they
know that I'm not only for gay marry
marriage but I'm gay married they know
that I'm pro-choice
they know that I'm for single-payer
health care they know that I'm for
euthanasia and I'd like to reform prison
systems and I'm not for nation-building
and all this other stuff and I think by
being human around them just by being
human I'm not even talking about what
we've done on air but when I hung out
with some of the privately I've seen
them sort of ease up on some of these
issues where people would oh they're all
homophobes and it's like no they're not
and if they were late to the party on
game air we look Republicans don't
really care about gay marriage anymore
they may not be thrilled about it but
Trump rants and it's okay and it's gonna
be alright and that's it and and that
sort of softening of of an ideology I
think we have to acknowledge that when
it happened like it's important for us
to say okay we wanted something for a
long time we thought it was right for a
long time they wave the white flag on
this one Oh doesn't mean they've come
around on everything else that I want
them to come around on you know but
sometimes they'll say you know I really
object to a lot of what you say and it's
offensive to my moral system but I
really like the way you presented it and
I thought you were fair
you've given me food for thought I don't
think I'll change my mind but thank you
for stimulating me to think wow I
haven't heard anything like that
from people I've disagreed with on the
left for quite some time
and I don't I don't know if I don't know
what's causing it I think part of it may
be that they were in an invisible war
that people couldn't see between these
mainstream publications and they would
specifically address this issue and not
that issue and now as the internet
culture has broken this game open maybe
they don't feel quite as embattled and
there they could choose to continue in
the previous trajectory but they're
actually saying no you know this Fitness
pays a dividend if you're if you're not
going to be so potent and hunting us and
making us feel like pariahs thanks
that's really interesting that they've
been hunted for so long and mocked by
mainstream for so long that now the
internet caused a crack people are
really able to look at them a little bit
differently and they're showing a little
a little humanity right now because they
realized that there's an opportunity to
be treated a little different it's
self-preservation by them but I'm fine
with that I believe in rational
self-interest in self-preservation right
and I think that you know it's shame on
anyone of us who doesn't accept a hand
that's offered in the spirit of
friendship and investigation of the
truth and I've had many hands offered to
me it doesn't mean I'm becoming them I
don't think that I've changed but you
know just as the point that I made to
you earlier once upon a time we had the
party of Lincoln and the Dixiecrats and
you know even if what all that's
happening is is that your end goals have
remained unchanged what gets bound to
those end goals like for example
interracial marriage of you know where
I'm in an interracial marriage it used
to be the Communist Party was the only
party that would support that right and
so now it's you know every party would
support it yeah but the point is is that
the labels and the bindings change and
I'm not going to be loyal you know just
to the Insignia so is that is that the
direct connection to their outrage that
they've owned the narrative for so long
because of mainstream accepting and
pushing these ideas academia media
politically what was okay to say and
what isn't okay to say that the Internet
came in blew it apart and now the reason
that they're so hysterical is because
they're finally under scrutiny
you know we had also got more dust
so if you look at like affirmative
action and the old you know decisions in
the 1970s you can make the claim that
the world had been so unequal that maybe
we needed to do something very radical
all right but you've now had these these
various corrective measures for so long
that even if we haven't gotten rid of
lots of structural problems things have
gotten a lot better on many more fronts
and I think if you look at something
like you know the Southern Poverty Law
Center what does it choose to do when it
runs through actual you know Klan
meetings because the darn enough
Klansmen to watch okay well you know now
we have to find some growth industry
so let's find like some of the most
enlightened helpful people around like
you know Maajid Nawaz and and we're
gonna go after him and paint a
bull's-eye
well mmm damn you yeah you don't know
you're not going to do that silently
it's not cute it's not funny you're
gonna get people killed you clearly
don't care yeah and thankfully ma Jude
is not taking it lying down he's now
preparing a I think he's preparing a
legal defense against or he may go on
the offense with them but they did it to
ion they did it to Brigitte Gabriel who
I've had on the show who I was a little
nervous about having her on the show
because so many people say she's this
right-wing evil you know monster I had
her on the show it was one of the most
enjoyable hours I've ever had of the
most decent person sitting across from
me telling me their story in their
humanity so let's make a point every
time they tell us who we're not supposed
to talk to let's put that person towards
the top of our list of people we should
probably talk to yeah we got to reverse
this thing because they need to lose
that toy right so they'll be playing too
much yeah what you know which which
camera can I look into you can look into
that one RA Tucker Carlson first of all
I haven't agreed with you very much over
the years thank you so much for covering
the story of Bret Weinstein I really
appreciate it and you know it's not it's
not a question if I'd begrudgingly say
this I'm just wholeheartedly open in
saying you know you you you you did
something that needed to be done and it
should have been done by
everyone should have been done by the
left and we're not apologetic about it
we're not apologizing left right and
center you know that was one of the huge
things with Brett when is he going to
apologize you watch he's gonna cave well
I've watched lots of people cave I even
wanted to bill Mahr cave mm-hmm you know
this is completely crazy and that
pressure is has been stood up to only on
the right so far as I know so credit
where it's due let's stop being scared
and by the way it doesn't mean that
we're moving I'm not moving to the right
in order to say this I know that I'm
just recognizing good work we're good
work is done yeah well that's a perfect
segue actually to another phrase that
you came up with that I love the
intersectional shakedown
so we've talked a lot about
intersectionality here I think most of
my audience understands that but this
shakedown Edition that you added I think
has a really interesting component it's
sort of related to everything that
happen to your brother I'm looking for
an apology from you and I'm looking for
concessions and what do I hold I hold
the ability to call you names and if you
don't do as I say if you will not
surrender your agency surrender your
individuality take on this junior status
which I'm going to call Ally white
people get me some water this is food
for black people in case black people
are hungry no what you're doing is
you're basically just baiting everybody
with the one tool you have which is if
you don't tow the line we're gonna call
you names and it's gonna limit your
ability to move around the institutional
universe so to be clear this is really a
critique of in the case of evergreen
this is a critique of the white students
that were joining the fray right because
they were sort of to prove how not
racist they were they were doing very
anti liberal things so the shakedown was
to take these guys and control these
students right absolutely it's a it's a
protection racket where fundamentally
you take the weakest people who are
embarrassed about their own culture
they're embarrassed about their own hi
and look everyone should look at their
own ethnic group and see what it does
well see what it does poorly is being
self-critical
is a virtue not a vice but self-hatred
and selfless and privileges the other as
some sort of advanced life-form as if we
can't I mean I do worry for example do
these white kids have any black friends
do they have any Muslim friends do they
have friends who immigrated from the
developing world because if you mean in
reality not in just you know if you were
to look
it all looks diverse yeah I mean people
who people who you'd trust to make
decisions for you in a hospital because
let me tell you the developing world
thinks that the West would be crazy to
give up on itself yes it's got more
entertaining dances or better food or
some rich and storied history and great
narratives and art but the fact of the
matter is is that the West has probably
more attraction from fur for those
people than any other place we are
amplifier is what distinguishes us we
have done everything more powerfully
than every other group and so it's not
whether or not what we're doing is right
or wrong because every culture does
right and wrong but our amplifier is
bigger so you know if you plug in a
Stratocaster to a huge stack built for a
stadium and you make a mistake I
guarantee you they're gonna hear it
three counties over around the other
hand if you play a fantastic solo that's
there too and I don't understand how
when did we give up on the West I mean
this has been terrible it's been
wonderful but it's the best thing we
have going hi there's a guy you know we
do this fan show that we do done a
couple of them where I interview 20
people from all over the world and the
first one that we did I introduced a guy
by the name I think he's about 25 by the
name of cushaw in India and we I follow
him on Twitter now and he messages me a
lot and he constantly is saying to me
how are you guys giving it up do you
realize you guys are giving it up I'm so
concerned for what's happening in your
country right now do you realize what's
happening it's it started to happen here
there's a lot of different things we
could talk about with India that's all
others whole other thing but every time
he says that I could feel it I can feel
it through the direct message like
somebody that sees so much what we're
just wasting
it's funny you bring up India I go to
India a lot and I have a one rule which
is if I want to make contact with India
and it's real culture I never allow
myself to become the honorary Indian
because I'm a terrible Indian I just
thought I didn't think I tried to speak
a little Hindi I care about the food the
music when I go over there I usually
bring a harmonica I sometimes bring a
baseball cap I amp up the American
because that says I'm not coming to the
potluck empty-handed I'm bringing my own
culture and I'm not trying to be a
junior version of you and people show up
at the potluck and manna you know are
they giving of the crown jewels of their
cultures and and you get that
appreciation when you show pride in
yourself because otherwise you won't be
able to receive the pride that they show
and the things that they want to tell
you yeah being a knight as curious as
you are about them they are about you
that's the that's the trade-off of
humanity aren't empty handed here and no
we're not we've got some good stuff all
right let's let's do 3 let's do 3 or 4
literally 2 minutes on each because then
I do want to get to this all right
artificial out telogen s-- yep so we
worry a lot about artificial
intelligence but it turns out that there
are lots of species that use the
intelligence of the target species that
they're parasitizing and make the victim
do the thinking in the service of the
predator and so we haven't worried about
evolving through artificial life because
computer programs are about the only
thing that humans can manufacture where
we can build in the reproductive system
as soon as it involves atoms you can't
get two glasses to make a third tumbler
I believe that almost all of the
prerequisites needed to build a system
that hijacks the intelligence of the
prey and mimics an intelligent system
using the intelligence of the victim are
in place and you can look at a video
that I did on big think that focuses on
this very quixotic but probably
near-term and prosper
so long before we get to artificial
intelligence we're going to get to
systems that use us to fool ourselves
and and are directed from a computer
which will do most of the heavy lifting
from what we fear from artificial
intelligence combat right we might be
doing it to ourselves right now you know
we'll link to the to that big fake video
which I have seen all right you know
we're just going to we're just going to
do one more right now we're gonna jump
in here this is probably the most
important one what is the ante expert ah
well going back to in the seam Talib
again
Nassim Taleb at some point was the best
person to get in front of the House
Committee on Finance order but it was
blocked because it had been sort of
captured by outside forces so I tried to
get him onto the House Science and
Technology Committee to tell us why the
world had blown up during the 2008
crisis and they launched every objection
to our friend the same and I said well
he doesn't he's not an academic I said
yes he is he's got a kind of Professor
oil position well he doesn't have a PhD
yes he does he doesn't publish PS he has
right he's at six foot four it turns out
that he has all of the right credentials
but he doesn't follow the conclusions
that the field has followed and so his
conclusions are different but the
problem is is that he's got much of the
credentials that that terrify the
community because it's like having
somebody say I'm a climate scientist
yeah I have completely different models
than you do let's talk technically and
we'll see where we're discordant and
somebody says well no no no that's this
is settled right well you know maybe I
have a different perspective on so an
anti expert isn't somebody who has all
of the same credentials as an expert but
has reached radically different
conclusions than their community and
still wants to remain in that kind of
dialogue to find out whether they're
right or they're wrong
and that person is usually somebody who
has to be shoved off to the side because
nobody in the field wants to have the
argument live with scorekeepers because
it will generally show that the
conclusions are not a nearly as strong
ground as they might be yeah
and everybody doesn't want to be
associated with
because then you will immediately be
smeared with the same things but well
this is this this tarring by association
and so you have these incredible chain
links which you know somebody knows
somebody who met with somebody who once
said good morning which is also
something that Joseph Goebbels
he was always saying good morning every
day alright we're gonna do we're do one
last thing here we're gonna do about ten
minutes on this because I have another
interview and then we've got something
later that we have to get to so a mirror
if you could pull up the four quadrant
image so I really want to dive into this
you thought the first time I heard about
this I what I'm correct me wrong it was
it the first time you had talked about
it publicly really was on Sam's podcast
it was okay so on Sam's waking up
podcasts which I'm sure most of my
audience probably listens to you
described this four quadrant method
really for for looking at the world and
there's a great video of it on on
YouTube but we're gonna have you re
explain it maybe you can do it a little
better this time we shall see so we've
so we're looking at it on the screen so
the audience can see you there we've got
copies in front of us so that you know
we don't have to extend our eyes too
much talk to me about the four quadrants
cuz this made a lot of sense to me and
but I can't tell you that I understood
every piece of it the first time you
explained it terrific
so it was a came out of a frustration
with left versus right thinking which I
think we all share we still use it
because it's slightly useful but it's
getting worse and worse as an
approximation all the time and I think
what I was trying to figure out is a
particular diameter is ever and over
again that we fall for just the way
Charlie Brown never manages to kick the
football from Lucy and so the idea is is
that you've got a collection of people
that I want to concentrate on as living
in the quadrant labeled first principles
thinkers and contrarians
mhm now these are people who are
thinking for themselves and are not
buying baked cakes they're buying the
ingredients and they're saying well I
want more of this ingredient I don't
like that ingredient so they're
attempting to avoid having any pre baked
idea put in front of them what you see
on the x-axis so we're in the upper left
quadrant right as video following
what you see on the on the on the x-axis
is some visible support for a policy
initiative are you for the DREAM Act do
you believe in No Child Left Behind do
you want the u.s. to accept more
refugees these are things that we can
measure whether you're supporting or
opposing a particular policy
prescription on the vertical axis what
you have is some implied moral virtue or
vice so let's start with somebody like
breath okay so Brett I think lives in
the second quadrant on the x-axis I'm
going to put support for the equity
agenda advanced by his college so he
clearly opposed that on the other hand
the I'm gonna put absence of racism on
the y-axis so I would say Brett is a chi
with like almost zero racism and
completely opposed to this equity agenda
sneak attack
so the problem is we sort of done one
good one bad there it's in the
traditional thing in traditional
thinking yeah now what they want to do
is to say ah we can infer from your
opposition to the equity agenda that
your real Y value is extremely negative
that is you are a racist and you oppose
these people because you singled out
black female strong black women who are
trying to advance a good cause and so
that is the attempt to map from quadrant
three sorry quadrant two first principle
Stingers contrarians into quadrant three
and you see this line actual position
perceived position so that's what they
tried to do they tried to create breath
the troglodyte breath the racist and in
fact that narrative which is you can
tell how good or bad somebody is on
racial or gender issues depending upon
how much they go along with
the agenda and that is the media
narrative and that's what broke right
which is that the New York Times
probably would say look this is part of
identity politics this is part of the
Democratic Party this is how we do
things we can't have people dining ala
carte buying ingredients this is a big
cake take it or leave it you were either
support the initiative and you're
virtuous on race or you oppose it and
you're a bastard right because otherwise
it's so contrary to everything else we
put out there we can't it can't make it
through the system right now let's take
somebody else for example let's take Sam
Harris okay so Sam Harris would normally
live in quadrant 2 along with Brett but
here for example free thinkers free
thinkers you know Sam might oppose
opening our borders for refugees coming
out of failed States particularly with
Muslim majority populations you would
like if you were part of the control
structure to say well that could only be
because you're an islamaphobe but my
guess is and I got Sam to admit this on
his podcast he seems to be a bit of an
Islamic I'll he's aware of the poetry
he's aware of the music he's aware of
the culture he's got very close friends
and collaborators or active practicing
Muslims and so the idea is that Sam is a
non he's probably an Islam affiliate guy
who's worried about the same thing his
Muslim friends are worried about needs
another label what was what he needed
but we're gonna drag him out yeah right
and so the key point is is that the
dupes are the people who say well you
know I can tell I can infer what Sam is
really up to he just wants a first
strike against Muslims in the Middle
East well obviously he doesn't that's
stupid now who's actually controlling
this game my claim is is that it these
people in the fourth quadrant which is
rent-seeking elite these are people who
for example want to save a pension plan
by increasing immigration because we're
not reproducing in growth you know is it
a low and so they for example may have a
very kind of mercenary self-interested
of why they want a border opened okay so
that's the elite level where would you
put like the people that relentlessly
slam and smear him for their own good
those are the dupes right on so the dupe
army yeah is going to come after you
relentlessly for breaking ranks and
saying I want to I want to dine a la
carte right and so for example I don't
see you as a trump supporter so if I did
this which would be like support for how
would I do you so in this case I might
say Dave is somebody who is opposed to
the mainstream news narrative absolutely
we want to but he is extremely
intellectual and very analytical and
trying to figure things out for himself
and we would like to say that he's
actually slid right so you'll see a ton
of stuff you know dave rubin refuses to
criticize x y&z he's actually a right
winger he's not a liberal bla bla bla
nonsense
yeah now what is this again they're
angry at you for in some sense dining
ala carte and over and over again it's
one trick which is you we want to break
out these long short positions which is
to say you know I'm long I'm long
Microsoft and I'm short Yahoo versus
somebody else who says no I you can only
be long tech or you have to be against
tech you can't actually have a view that
one tech company is on the way up and
one tech company is on the way down and
so I believe that this diagram we all
need to understand it because what's
happening is is that we're being
attacked individually each one of us has
a custom one of these fitted to us as to
what's wrong with us what's wrong with
Eric that he's ragging on the New York
Times I feel like journalism is so
important right well of course I feel
like journalism would be important
somebody should invent it I just don't
sandwich right and so it's not against
that it's it's a point of saying I have
I hold a long short nuanced position and
what are you going to try to do the
easiest way to neutralize me is to try
to map me to the troglodyte sector and
and how are you going to do that
it's always the same game we have the
right to infer what you're really up to
from some bit of observed behavior thank
you very much your words mean nothing
the nuances are all lost we've got your
number next please the only way that
works is that some of us are still
dependent on institutions so the
institutions are still playing that game
but here and this was my point to you
earlier here we are in a non-network
right we're in somebody's very
professional studio able to reach people
so that I get recognized in airports and
coffee shops and the fact is we're out
of control and that's why they're coming
for us now is because they're starting
to understand well what happens if sam
harris and dave rubin and erik weinstein
sargon of akkad and Laci green and
Philly D all these people actually start
saying are you seeing the same craziness
I am whether it's on D monetization
whether it's on Facebook thankfully
making sure that face that fake news is
out of my feed well what you're really
gonna start doing is filtering a bunch
of stuff that isn't fake yeah it's just
stuff that's off your narrative or
Google is gonna bury it in their
algorithms so it's going to be there but
it's gonna be seven pages and you'll
never see it we got a lot of work to do
well we've got two possible ways out so
far as I can see or we can just start up
history and earnest and try to see
whether we land safely but I would
certainly take either of the first two
options either D Potemkin eyes the
institutions or reboot from a ragtag
collection of of kids who look something
like the Bad News Bears but might be
able to get the job done I'm on the
reboot side yeah the other one just
simply doesn't seem possible to me and I
think the rebooting has begun now we
need a lot of allies we need a lot of
help but I think it's I think the
Calvary is coming well I'm here for the
second time and that should tell you
something about how I'm voting I wish we
could do it the other way because it'd
be easier but there's no time to lose
and semi reliable communal sense making
is the number one crisis if we do not
learn
how to come up with a narrative that we
can share where we can have small
differences but everybody more or less
agrees on the general facts without
turning everything into a political
contest we're gonna take the most
hopeful and best experiment with all of
its flaws throw every bad thing that
happened to the 20th century and we're
still better off not trashing this
experiment and protecting it and I'll
come back anytime you want I love it my
friend you want to eat some good food
and drink some good wine tonight that
sounds like a plan and that is what we
shall do you guys know where to find it
but for more on Eric follow them on the
twitter at Eric our Weinstein I've got
one more interview coming up with
economist Pia Mulaney later today but
that's gonna go up in a couple weeks so
I hope you've enjoyed the live streams
that we did today and and we did some
behind the scenes stuff with Lacey we're
gonna do something with Eric which is
will also be exclusive on patreon so
it's patreon.com slash Ruben Report and
that's all I got for ya I think I think
we did all right today all right there
you go
[Music]